the stakes are very high this week we
are losing half of the contestants I
mean for you guys it I would imagine is
it is it emotional it's a lot of people
to go and there's no there's no even
mediocre singers left they're all like
really good and the to imagine that for
them we'll go home today is like it's
hard for me to envision even last week
people were going home that shouldn't
you don't mean like this season has just
been full of talent and so it's been
really inspiring to be around all these
amazing people talented singers and
going into tonight you are kind of
leading the charge do you feel a
pressure to go back to back no and the
thing is having the most singers and the
semifinals or the finale you saw last
year Blake had three people in the
finale but male in one so all it takes
is one singer to win Rose could win you
know anybody on anybody's team could win
it's not a matter of who's got the most
on their team so I'm just ruined for all
of them to be individually their best
and and hopefully America will be
convinced as we know anything can happen
on this show do you guys have side bets
between the judges no we definitely
talked about it like I mean Blake
definitely talked about it and it's hard
cuz like even in between like commercial
breaks we'll be like wow I didn't think
that was gonna happen like are you
kidding like before Kelly we like this
is gonna happen as it did of that and
then it doesn't happen she's like yeah I
was wrong you know like I said anything
can happen on this show and I know it's
it's friendly rivalry between you and
Blake in particular but I have to say I
did have a sneak peek at his upcoming
album and the track that you were
featured on with him nobody about you is
absolutely beautiful obviously John you
will not use big P you will weep so the
song reflects on a life that has been
bettered by a loving relationship how
would you say Blake has made you a
better person
good very good question Blake saved my
life everybody knows that like and we
are just having the time of our lives
and we never expected that this late in
our lives so we're just trying to savor
every moment together and just to be
back here on the voice as well has been
not to change the subject but
I'm just saying like together working
together again has been really really
fun and I love being here and I love
being with him so it's like them being
on the show together it brings a nice
energy to the show I had no idea but I
love the energy with them being on the
show together it it kind of softens
Blake a little bit in the right ways he
did say he doesn't remember life before
you are your eyes watery yes
[Music]